This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。绝对真人。嗨，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的生活经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对无法畅所欲言的坦诚对话，而这一切都是在一位知其所以然的持证专业人士的陪伴下进行的。有多少男人披着一副盔甲。它向全世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，就必须这样做。听听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
如何在I-Heart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方汲取《艰难成长的教训》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后，变成一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2%”，在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的世纪骗子时，她们决定采取行动，亲手讨回公道。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他必须付出应有的代价。我们总是说，要相信你的好闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hi, everyone, new listeners, old new listeners, friends, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, strangers, uh, welcome to the podcast. and to this week's topic of discussion, which is the breakup. Yes, ladies and gentlemen, the breakup. Such a big part of our lives, such a big part of our 20s, when I think the majority of us experience our first type of real and serious heartbreak
在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。哈喽，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时遇到的一些重大变化和人生转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，新听众、老朋友、新来的新听众、朋友们、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、陌生人、呃，欢迎来到本期播客。以及本周的讨论话题，也就是分手。是的，女士们先生们，分手。这是我们生活中的重大事件，是我们20多岁时的一个重大经历，我觉得我们绝大多数人都经历过第一次真正而深刻的心碎，
and, you know, the breakups and the relationships we have in our 20s are just going to impact us way down the line. So I thought we should finally discuss it. This is going to be a pretty big episode, I think a hard episode, a sad episode, but also one of, you know, healing and thriving, getting through your heartbreak and hopefully coming out of it as a better person. And if you're here and listening, I'm sending you a lot of love and support because I'm guessing that you're listening for a reason, most likely because you're going through
而且，你知道的，我们在20多岁时经历的分手和恋爱，会对我们的未来产生深远的影响。所以我想我们终于应该来聊聊这个话题了。这将是一个相当沉重的话题，我觉得会是一个艰难的话题，一个悲伤的话题，但同时也是一个关于治愈和成长、度过心碎期并最终蜕变成一个更好的人的话题。如果你来到了这里并在收听节目，我想向你致以满满的爱与支持，因为我猜你收听是有原因的，很可能是因为你现在正经历着
this right now. And we've all been there in the midst of, you know, a breakup where the grief just feels overwhelming. So hopefully what we talk about today will offer you some guidance or at least a sense of solace that you're not in and alone, that you're not the first one to go through this. And, you know, time passes. That's the beautiful thing about time. It always keeps me moving forward and you will as well. That sounded so sappy, but I hope you know what I mean. So I have been working, writing, re-planning, reworking and thinking about this episode for over a year.
这一切。我们都曾经历过分手的痛苦，那种悲伤简直让人无法呼吸。所以希望我们今天聊的内容能为你提供一些指导，或者至少带来一丝慰藉，让你知道你并不孤单，你不是第一个经历这种痛苦的人。而且，你知道的，时间会流逝。这就是时间美妙的地方。它总是带着我不断向前，你也会如此。听起来可能有点老套，但我希望你明白我的意思。所以，为了制作这一期节目，我已经筹备、撰写、重新规划、反复修改并思考了一年多的时间。
In fact, when I first began this podcast, it was one of the main things, the main topics that I really wanted to get around to discussing. But every time I've revisited the subject, I just felt that I couldn't. I was at a place where I could objectively view heartbreak and a breakup and not feel like I was still in one myself. Basically, I wasn't sure if I could, you know, record this from a wise place or not cry. And, you know, this is a really vulnerable topic. And I know that, you know, friends and family are probably listening to this, which is great. Hello.
事实上，当我刚开始做这个播客时，这就是我最想探讨的核心内容之一、最核心的话题。但每次我重新触及这个主题时，我都觉得自己还做不到。我当时还没能达到一种状态，能够客观地看待心碎和分手，而不觉得自己依然深陷其中。简而言之，我不确定自己能否站在一个智者的角度来录制这期节目，或者保证不哭。而且，你知道的，这是一个非常脆弱的话题。我也知道，朋友和家人可能都在收听，这很好。哈喽。
But yeah, safe space to share, I feel like, and to link up with the people who are in the same. same place as you. And I think now I can, now I can record this episode, I believe, more on that later. But yeah, I'm in a wiser place about it. So I was like, let's give it a crack. Actually, a bit of podcast history. I actually began this podcast after a pretty serious breakup I went through last year with, yeah, with the guy I was seeing at the time who, yeah, with this person. I went through a break up with them and I was at a really low place in terms of my self-esteem, keeping myself occupied with all of my free time I had because I wasn't with this person anymore and, you know, recreating myself, how I saw myself. And this podcast was just such a savior for me to heal
不过，是的，我觉得这里是一个安全的空间，可以用来分享，并与那些和你处于同样处境的人建立连接。我觉得现在我可以了，现在我相信我可以录制这期节目了，关于这一点稍后细聊。总之，我对这件事有了更成熟的看法。所以我想，那就尝试一下吧。说实话，这也是播客的一点历史。我其实是在去年经历了一次相当严重的分手后才开始做这个播客的，当时的对象是，嗯，当时和我交往的那个男生，也就是，嗯，和这个人。我和他分手了，当时我的自尊心跌到了谷底，我用各种空闲时间来填满自己，因为我不再和这个人在一起了，你知道的，我不得不重新塑造自己，重新审视自我。而这个播客简直就是我的救星，让我能够疗愈
and grow as a person, as a person that was beyond them, that was no longer attached to them. So I am very grateful to this podcast, the people who have listened and how much it's grown out of that vision I had for initially. And it's helped me so massively. And it's just like unbelievable what it's become. So thank you to those who have supported me. I really appreciate it. So I truly believe that there is a certain reverence to being heartbroken,
并作为一个人成长，成为一个超越了那段关系、不再依附于任何人的人。所以我非常感谢这个播客、那些一直以来收听的听众，以及它从我最初的愿景发展到今天的规模。它对我的帮助太大了。它能发展成现在这样简直不可思议。所以感谢所有支持我的人。我真的非常感激。因此，我真心认为，心碎其实也是一种带有敬畏感的过程，
to building yourself back up from such a low point where you have lost someone you cared for so deeply. There's something spiritual about the process of, feeling emotions so intensely and being able to adjust to them and move forward. It's a significant grieving process that I can imagine many of you are currently in. I think I also went through a period. No, I don't think. I know. I went through a period of that recently as well. And though I probably wouldn't call it a breakup, it certainly felt that way. And it still really hurts. There are times when I miss this person really intensely and I wish I could tell them about the things I see
从如此低谷中重新振作起来，你失去了那个你曾深深关爱的人。这种经历情感如此剧烈、并最终学会适应它们并继续前进的过程，带有某种精神层面的意义。这是一个深刻的悲伤过程，我想你们当中许多人目前正身处其中。我想我也经历过这样一段时期。不，我不只是觉得。我很清楚。我最近也经历过这样一段时期。尽管我可能不会称之为分手，但那种感觉确实如此。而且它仍然真的很痛。有时我会非常强烈地思念这个人，真希望自己能把看到的趣事告诉他，
and message them about things that remind me of them. And we'll go through how you can move through those periods of longing and grief, how you can move forward with your life and, you know, with respect and admiration for that person and everything they contributed to your life, but leaving the love you had for them behind and solidly in the past. We'll talk more about that later. Love is not always easy or straightforward. And I think the majority of the times we do choose to put ourselves out there and have a deep connection with someone,
把那些让我想起他的事情发信息分享给他。接下来我们将探讨你该如何度过那些渴望与悲伤的时期，如何带着对那个人的尊重与钦佩、以及对他们为你生活所做一切的感激继续生活，同时把曾经对他们的爱留在过去，让它彻底成为过去式。我们稍后会详细谈谈这一点。爱情并不总是简单直接的。我想，大多数时候，当我们选择敞开心扉、与某人建立深层连接时，
we risk being profoundly hurt. But I guess the message of this episode that I really want to convey is that it's always worth it. The growth you see in yourself, the ability to recreate yourself, to remind yourself of your strength and why you are fucking amazing is just such an incredible reward. You know, also just the fact that you lean on your friends and your family and your hobbies so much more intensely and you're just going to see so much growth in. and reward in that area of your life as well after a breakup.
我们都在冒着遭受重创的风险。但我猜本期节目真正想要传达的信息是，这一切绝对是值得的。你在自己身上看到的成长、重塑自我的能力、以及让你重新认识到自己的坚强和为什么自己如此了不起，这一切都是无与伦比的回报。你知道的，这也是因为你开始更加依赖你的朋友、家人和各种爱好，而在分手之后，你会在生活的这些方面看到巨大的成长和回报。
Some of the moments of, you know, the greatest change and growth and significance in my life has come after periods of heartache. And I look back at the person I was before and I can't even recognize her anymore because I am profoundly different. You are profoundly different after you have loved and lost. No matter how significant that relationship was, it could have been for three months, could have been for six, could have been for years. But I guess I am speaking to people in their 20s.
我人生中一些最大的改变、成长和具有重大意义的时刻，都出现在经历心碎的时期之后。每当我回看以前的自己，我甚至都快认不出她了，因为我已经发生了翻天覆地的变化。在经历过爱与失去之后，你也会发生深刻的改变。无论那段感情多么重要，可能持续了三个月，可能持续了六个月，也可能持续了好几年。不过我想我主要是对20多岁的人说这些，
where, you know, I don't think many of us have met the loves of our lives yet. Maybe you have congratulations, but it ultimately means that you're going to have to probably go through this at least once or twice before you get there. But being able to, you know, look at who you were before, look at who you are now and think about who you are and could be. Who you could be in the future is just such a beautiful part of that process. And I had this recently. I went back to Canberra where I went to uni and spent a lot of time. and I just realized how much I had grown since I was last there and when I was living there. And I felt so sad.
在这个年纪，你知道的，我觉得我们大多数人还没遇到此生的真爱。也许你遇到了，那恭喜你，但这最终意味着，在你找到真爱之前，你可能不得不至少经历一两次这样的痛苦。但是，能够审视自己曾经是谁，看看现在的自己，思考你是谁以及你可能成为谁，思考你未来会成为什么样的人，这其实是这个过程中非常美丽的一部分。我最近就有了这种体验。我回到了坎培拉，也就是我上大学、度过很多时光的地方，
I felt so sad for the person I was when I was there and I missed those memories and those people that I loved in that place. But I was also so grateful and proud for what I chose to do after periods of hurt. And I was proud of myself for, you know, I guess standing up for myself, not being with those people anymore, realizing that I did deserve better. And I did a bit of a survey of my life and I just felt so much gratitude for those people and for myself because I guess you put in the work
我突然意识到，自从我上次离开、自从我在这里生活以来，自己已经成长了这么多。我当时感到非常难过。我为自己当年在这里时的状态感到难过，我也怀念那些记忆，以及我在那个地方爱过的人。但我同时也为自己在经历伤痛后所做出的选择感到无比的感激和骄傲。我为自己能够，嗯，我想是为自己挺身而出、不再和那些人纠缠、意识到自己确实值得拥有更好的一切而感到自豪。我对自己的人生进行了一番盘点，对那些人以及对我自己充满了感激，因为我觉得你付出了努力，
and it pays off. And one day you get to kind of look around and be like, wow, I did it. I like move past those periods of like shittiness. And I also think this is a period of my life. I think it's like the first time in like five years that I haven't either been, you know, heartbroken, dating or falling in love.
它就会得到回报。而总有一天，你会环顾四周，心想：哇，我做到了。我走出了那些糟糕透顶的日子。而且我也认为，这是我人生中的一个阶段，大概是我五年来第一次，既没有心碎、没有约会，也没有陷入热恋。
And what a liberating feeling that is And if you're in your own breakup right now, which I am assuming you are, I hope that's something to look forward to. Okay, I'm really sorry for the ramble. I guess it's a vulnerable subject, though. So if you're not here for the vulnerability, you're probably not here for the right reasons. But let me give you an overview of what I am planning to discuss today. So we're going to talk about the biology and the underlying kind of physical reactions that
这种感觉是多么的解放啊。如果你现在也正经历分手，我想你大概率是的，我希望这能成为一件让你有所期待的事。好吧，为我刚才的絮絮叨叨感到抱歉。不过我想这是一个脆弱的话题。所以，如果你不是来寻找这种脆弱共鸣的，那你可能来错地方了。不过，让我先概述一下我今天打算讨论的内容。我们将讨论分手的生物学原理以及背后的一些生理反应，
many breakups contain and that make breakups so hard. There is, like most things, a science to it all that we will discuss. And we'll talk about grief and how to move through the stages of grief associated with the breakup and then eventually how you move on. Also, can you be friends with your ex? Well, I'm going to speak from experience and say, yes, we can, but it has a few conditions. And I think it's a question that a lot of us ask ourselves when we're in a breakup. Like, I just want to be friends with them. I just want to, you know, as long as we stay friends. So that's also a point of contention, but also discussion that I want to think about with you, discuss with you. So all you heartbroken people out there, welcome, strap yourself in and yeah, prepare for a brilliant
许多分手都会伴随这些反应，这也是分手如此难熬的原因。和大多数事情一样，这一切背后都有科学依据，我们稍后会讨论。我们还会讨论悲伤，以及如何度过与分手相关的不同悲伤阶段，最后是如何真正走出来。还有，你能和前任做朋友吗？好吧，我将从经验出发说：是的，我们可以，但有几个前提条件。我想这也是我们在经历分手时经常问自己的一个问题。比如，我只想和他们做朋友。我只想，你知道的，只要我们能保持朋友关系就行。所以这也是一个存在争议、但我也想和你一起思考和探讨的话题。所以，所有心碎的人们，欢迎来到这里，系好安全带，准备迎接这精彩的
episode. I don't know, an informative episode and one that hopefully you can relate to. So the first thing I want to talk about is the biology, the science, the psychology behind breakups. What does it mean from, I guess, a brain sense, from a mind sense? What's actually happening up there? Why does this hurt? Why does this hurt so much? So a big part of it is, of course, to do with neurotransmitters. I'm sure you probably guess that. Neurotransmitters are basically, hopefully I'm not explaining this if you already know, but basically they're these little chemicals in our brain that allow for communication. You know, the fuel that the brain kind of relies on to communicate messages and to get us to act and do things.
一期节目吧。好吧，这是一期内容丰富、且希望你能感同身受的节目。所以，我要谈论的第一件事就是生物学、科学、以及分手背后的心理学。从大脑和思维的角度来看，这究竟意味着什么？我们的脑袋里到底发生了什么？为什么这会痛？为什么分手会这么痛？其中很大一部分原因当然与神经递质有关。我敢说你大概也能猜到。神经递质基本上，希望我在你已经知道的前提下不用过多解释，它们本质上就是我们大脑中那些允许细胞间进行交流的小化学物质。
And our neurotransmitters play a pretty big role in feelings like love. And then the subsequent feelings of hurt when it doesn't work out. The primary ones are serotonin and dopamine. We hear a lot about them. good reason. So there was this study done around a breakup and around love that shows that addiction and love are actually very, very similar. So in this study, there's a psychologist. She had two groups of people and one group were, you know, intensely in love, falling in love and the other group had been broken up with. And she showed them pictures of, you know, their beloved, the people
它们是大脑用来传递信息、驱动我们行动和做事的燃料。我们的神经递质在诸如爱情之类的感觉中扮演着非常重要的角色。而在感情无疾而终时，随之而来的痛苦感也与此息息相关。其中最主要的两种是血清素和多巴胺。我们经常听到它们，这是有充分理由的。曾经有一项关于分手和爱情的研究表明，戒断成瘾和失恋其实非常、非常相似。在这项研究中，有一位心理学家。她找了两组人，其中一组是，深陷爱河、正在坠入爱河的人，而另一组则是刚刚经历分手的人。她向他们展示了，他们所爱之人的照片，也就是那些
that they loved. And when she showed it to the people who were actively in love, the same areas lit up in their brain as you would expect when, you know, you would see when someone would do like heroin or when you got a massive dopamine hit from gambling or from intense exercise. Anything that is addictive activates the same parts of our brains that love does, which is really interesting and really accounts for, I think, that really intense period where you're first meeting someone and getting to know them where you're just obsessed and you love them and you're just thinking about what they could do no wrong,
他们深爱的人。当她把照片展示给那些正处于热恋中的人时，他们大脑中被激活的区域，正如你所预料的那样，和某人吸食海洛因时，或者当你从赌博中获得巨大的多巴胺刺激、或进行高强度运动时被激活的区域是一样的。任何会让人上瘾的事物都会激活我们大脑中与爱情相同的部位，这真的非常有趣，我觉得这也很好地解释了那段最初相遇、了解彼此的强烈时期——你会感到痴迷，你爱上了对方，满脑子都是对方，觉得对方怎么做都是对的，
thinking about all the future plans, all the amazing things about them. And at its essence, what the psychologist is saying is that it's addiction, is that dopamine, the dopamine in our brain is creating pathways really quickly that make you want to have more of a fix and make you more connected to this person or a neurological level. So then she showed these photos of people, you know, people that were connected to the participants to the people who had just been broken up with. Here's the thing, those same areas lit up.
幻想着未来所有的计划，想着他们身上所有美好的地方。从本质上讲，这位心理学家所说的就是，这是一种成瘾，我们大脑中的多巴胺正在极快地建立神经通路，让你想要获得更多这种“多巴胺奖励”，并在神经层面上让你与这个人的联系更加紧密。然后，她向那些刚刚经历分手的人展示了这些照片，展示了那些与参与者有关的人的照片。有趣的是，同样的区域也被激活了。
But something else happened as well. Firstly, they lit up just as much, but it took longer to die down. So what that means is that you're not getting the same hit or fix. you know, your brain gets activated to receive a reward and you don't get it. And what ends up happening is withdrawal. So your brain sends out all these messages of like, oh my gosh, we're going to get this reward. You know, we've seen this person that's like a hit or it's a rush of like some drug. And in the people who were in love, you know, they were rewarded by that. They knew that those feelings of love would be reciprocated. They could go back to that person and get that
但同时还发生了别的事情。首先，它们的激活程度同样很高，但消退的时间却更长。这意味着你并没有获得同等程度的快感或满足。你知道的，你的大脑被激活去接受奖励，但你却没有得到它。最终导致的结果就是戒断反应。所以你的大脑会发出各种各样的信号，比如：“哦天哪，我们要得到奖励了。”你知道的，我们看到了这个人，这就像是一次毒瘾发作，或者是一剂猛烈的药物冲击。对于那些身处爱中的人来说，
hit. But for the people who were in a breakup, their brains were no longer getting that hit and it caused genuine withdrawal, genuine withdrawal symptoms within their brain, a crash within their brain, a dopamine crash. And this other group of researchers, they studied young adults who experienced a recent unwanted breakup. So they were broken up with. And when participants viewed photos of their exes, their ventraltgmental area, so basically it's the VTA. And this nucleus in the center of their brain where the dopamine center, is they all lit up with activity and these regions are tied to our brain's reward system. Specifically dopamine, which we've talked about that causes feelings of euphoria and addiction.
他们的爱得到了回报。他们知道这种爱意是相互的。他们可以回到那个人身边，再次获得那种快感。但对于经历分手的人来说，他们的大脑再也无法获得那种快感了，这在大脑中引起了真正的戒断，真正的戒断症状，大脑的多巴胺水平随之崩塌。另一组研究人员对最近经历了一场非自愿分手的年轻人进行了研究。也就是说他们是被甩的那一方。当参与者看到他们前任的照片时，他们的腹侧被盖区，也就是VTA，以及位于大脑中心的多巴胺核心区域，
And in the face of a breakup, your brain stimulates the addiction. The dopamine signals your brain to crave an object or a person that previously caused the euphoria for you to crave them in the first place. So our reward or motivation system means that we're now driven to find the source of our joy and to find that person, but we don't have access to them anymore. They're not ours. So you basically have that crash. You have that high and you have that crash.
都亮起了活跃的活动信号，这些区域与我们大脑的奖励系统紧密相连。特别是多巴胺，我们之前讨论过，它会带来欣快感和成瘾感。而在面对分手时，你的大脑会进一步刺激这种成瘾。多巴胺会向你的大脑发送信号，让你渴望那个曾经给你带来欣快感的事物或人，让你从一开始就对他们魂牵梦绕。因此，我们的奖励或动机系统意味着，我们现在本能地想要找到快乐的源泉，去寻找那个人，但我们已经无法接近他们了。他们不再属于你了。所以基本上你会经历这种落差。你体验过高潮，然后迎来了坠落。
Kind of also explains, you know, those like awkward drunk text that you like send your ex when you're really drunk and you're like looking at photos of them or like thinking of them. And your brain's like, oh, I know how we can get a hit. Let's just like message them out of the blue. Don't do it. Never works. I feel like, yeah, let's just steer clear of that.
这也顺便解释了，为什么有时喝醉酒后，当你看着前任的照片或想着他们时，会给前任发一些尴尬的醉酒短信。你的大脑会说：“哦，我知道怎么能爽一把了。我们直接给他们发个信息吧。”千万别这么做。这从来不管用。我觉得，嗯，我们还是离这远点吧。
Another part of our kind of internal systems and our neurological systems that contributes to the pain of a breakup is this thing called long-term potentiation. I've talked about this on the podcast before. You all know the term you use it or you lose it. But there is kind of a reverse of that as well. The more you use a pathway, the stronger it becomes. So when you've been with someone, when you've been with them for a while, when you've built up memories and connections and patterns of behavior with them, your brain creates, you know, simultaneously creates patterns of synapses and patterns of neurons that reflect those activities, that reflect those feelings.
我们内部系统和神经系统中的另一个部分，也是导致分手痛苦的原因，被称为“长时程增强”。我在之前的播客里谈过这个。你们都知道“用进废退”这个词。但其实也有相反的情况。你使用某个神经通路的次数越多，它就会变得越强大。所以，当你和某人在一起时，当你和他们在一起一段时间后，当你和他们建立起记忆、连接和行为模式时，你的大脑会同时创建突触模式和神经元模式，来反映这些活动、反映这些感受。
And then you break up with them. And, you know, whilst they may be gone, those neurological patterns and pathways in your brain associated with that person, they're still there. They didn't go anywhere. So your brain continues to fire signals along those pathways that creates a sense of craving and it takes a while for those pathways to die out. I guess that's the great part of you know you use it or you lose it. You can lose it. If you don't act on those reactions or those impulses to talk to that person, to see that person, to connect with that person, slowly those pathways that are associated with your feelings for them, they'll die. They will no longer be used and the brain will be like, okay, well, let's replace that with something better.
然后你们分手了。你知道的，虽然对方可能已经离开，但你大脑中与那个人相关的那些神经模式和通路依然存在。它们哪里也没去。所以你的大脑会继续沿着这些通路发送信号，从而产生一种强烈的渴望，这些通路需要一段时间才会消退。我想这就是“用进废退”中好的一面，你可以“废”掉它们。如果你不顺从那些想要和对方说话、想要见对方、想要和对方连接的反应或冲动，慢慢地，那些与你对他们的感情相关的神经通路就会消退。它们将不再被使用，而大脑会想：“好吧，那我们用更好的东西来替代它吧。”
In a breakup, you also feel a lot of physical symptoms as well. So MRI scans and some other neuroscience studies have shown that the withdrawal of romantic love activates the same parts of the brain, which are activated when we go through withdrawal. So it also sends the same signals to your body to pay attention to certain things, and it creates physical pain as well. So these MRI scans showed that there are several areas of the brain which contribute to that. Basically, what it means is your brain is addicted to something and when it can't get it, it sends signals to your body to do so, to go out and find it.
在分手时，你还会感受到许多生理上的症状。所以磁共振成像（MRI）扫描和其他一些神经科学研究表明，浪漫之爱的戒断会激活大脑中与我们经历药物戒断时相同的区域。它还会向你的身体发送信号，去关注某些特定的事情，并产生真正的生理痛苦。这些MRI扫描显示，大脑中有好几个区域都参与其中。基本上，这意味着你的大脑对某种事物上瘾了，当它无法得到时，就会向身体发送信号去行动，去把那个东西找回来。
You know, you might feel physically ill. You might feel like nauseous. You might feel incredibly tired or anxious or jittery. fatigue, muscle aches, headaches, all of these are symptoms of what you would expect from, you know, drug withdrawal, but love is the best drug, I guess. And so you're expecting and it's expected that you'll also experience that when you go through a breakup. The other component, which is more of a social element, I think, but equally as important, is that when you date someone and when you love someone, your identity becomes intertwined with them. There are parts of you that you associate
你可能会觉得身体很不舒服。你可能会感到恶心。你可能会感到难以置信的疲惫、焦虑或紧张。疲劳、肌肉酸痛、头痛，所有这些都是药物戒断时会出现的典型症状，不过我想爱情是最好的毒品。所以当你经历分手时，你也会经历这些反应，这是完全可以预期的。另一个组成部分，我认为更偏向于社会层面，但同样重要，那就是当你与某人恋爱、爱上某人时，你的自我认同会与对方交织在一起。你身上有些部分是你和他们联系在一起的，
with them that they've had kind of a hand in. You know, love and romance, I'm sure we've all seen it, it also creates codependence where you're relying on that person for support and for love and for validation. And when you can no longer get that, your sense of self really crumbles and diminishes because you no longer have that support structure to hold you up. You just feel weakened without it. brain kind of does weird things with that as well. I don't know if you've had this, but, you know, these people that you've broken up with that you're not with anymore, they show up in your dreams. They, like, I remember I, like, a few months ago, I was just having like vivid, vivid dreams of this person showing up and it felt so real because my brain was still trying to use those old
他们也在其中起到了塑造的作用。爱情和浪漫，我相信我们都见证过，它也会产生共生依赖，你会依靠那个人来获得支持、爱和认可。而当这些不再可得时，你的自我感就会真正崩溃和瓦解，因为你不再拥有那个支撑你站立的支持结构。没有了它，你会觉得自己变得脆弱不堪。大脑在这方面也会搞一些奇怪的把戏。我不知道你有没有这种经历，但是，那些你已经分手、不再在一起的人，会出现在你的梦里。他们会，我记得几个月前，我总是做一些非常生动的梦，梦到这个人出现，感觉是那么真实，因为我的大脑仍然试图使用那些我们正试图关闭的旧神经通路。
pathways that, you know, we were trying to shut down. And also because they had been a big part of my life. So there were all of the, I wasn't having them in my life. So my brain was kind of, creating situations for me in which I got to have that kind of fix. It also might be why, you know, you do also feel your self-esteem and your self-confidence really kind of go down the toilet because like we were talking about with that social element of your identity, becoming intertwined with them, you no longer have that validation and reinforcement from someone you truly loved. And your confidence just kind of drops. I had that recently.
而且因为他们曾经是我生活中的重要一部分。所以所有这些，虽然他们已经不在我的生活中了。但我的大脑还是为我创造了一些情境，让我能够重新获得那种“精神满足”。这也可能就是为什么，你知道的，你的自尊心和自信心会真的跌到谷底，因为就像我们之前讨论过的关于自我认同的社会层面一样，你的身份与他们交织在一起，你不再能从那个你真正爱过的人那里获得认可和鼓励。你的自信心就会随之下降。我最近就有这种感觉。
I just felt so low and so, like, crappy about myself because I could no longer look to this person to kind of lift me up, not that they really did anyways, but in the ways that they would show you affection or they would show you that you cared, or show you that they cared about you, you don't have that anymore. So what do you have to replace it with?
我觉得自己太糟糕、太逊了，因为我再也不能指望这个人来振奋我了——尽管他们本来也没有怎么这样做过——但在他们原本会向你表达爱意、或是向你展示他们关心你、或是向你展示他们其实在乎你的那些方式上，你再也得不到这些了。那你拿什么来替代它呢？
You know, in the initial stage of the breakup, nothing really seems to fill that hole the same way that they did, which is really tough and it all kind of links together. That's why you just feel so crap and you feel so shitty because there are physical and social and mental and psychological reactions going on in your brain. That is to do with withdrawal and that is to do with no longer having access to that fix or that sense of companionship with that person. So now that we understand where those shitty feelings are coming from, I want to talk about grief. I think losing a relationship, losing someone you love, not permanently as in they're dead, but
你知道的，在分手的初期，没有什么东西能真正填补那个洞，就像他们曾经填补的那样，这真的很难熬，这一切都是环环相扣的。这就是为什么你会感觉那么糟糕、那么烂，因为你的大脑中正在发生生理、社会、心理和精神上的各种反应。这与戒断反应有关，也与无法再从那个人那里获得满足感或陪伴感有关。既然我们已经明白了这些糟糕感觉的来源，接下来我想谈谈悲伤。我认为失去一段感情，失去你爱的人——不是指他们死了那种永久性的失去，而是
losing someone you're no longer with is this type of grief. Having to say goodbye to that person and what you had and what you could have had in the future is grief. And I do truly believe that there are stages of grieving to a breakup, just like there are stages of grieving with a death. For those who don't know, the five stages are denial, anger, bargaining, depression and acceptance. Let's apply these to heartbreak, to a breakup. Denial, that's probably the first two weeks, I'd say, for most of us, where it's just like, this isn't happening. Everything is as normal. Everything is, we're just going about our business. And it's where you don't really feel anything. You know, you're full of, like, opportunities for what you can do, you know, like, now it
失去一个你不再与之在一起的人——也是一种悲伤。必须对那个人、对你们曾经拥有的一切、以及对你们未来可能拥有的一切说再见，这就是悲伤。我真心相信，分手也有悲伤的各个阶段，就像面对亲人离世一样。对于那些不知道的人来说，这五个阶段分别是：否认、愤怒、讨价还价、抑郁和接受。让我们把这些应用到心碎和分手上。否认，这大概是前两周吧，对我们大多数人来说，当时的心态就是：“这没有发生。一切都很正常。一切都在继续，我们只是在过我们自己的日子。”在这个阶段你其实感觉不到什么。你知道的，你充满了各种可以去做的事情的机会，比如，“现在我可以和别人约会了。现在我可以，
can date other people. Now I can, you know, hang out with my friends. Let's go drinking. Let's like, you know, go gym heaps. Like, whatever you decide to do. Essentially, it's just like, the emotions haven't hit you yet. You're still in denial about what is actually happening. Next comes anger. Anger is just such a severe stage, I think, of grief, but one that you just have to work through. Anger at yourself, anger at the person, anger at the situation. I remember finding myself so angry at myself for allowing myself to be in, you know, a relationship that wasn't suiting me for so long and now I'm having to go through this period of like intense heartbreak. I should have just like not, you know, started it to begin with, which is ridiculous.
你知道的，和朋友出去玩。我们去喝酒吧。我们去，你知道的，疯狂健身吧。”无论你决定做什么。本质上就是，情绪还没有冲击到你。你还在否认实际正在发生的事情。接下来是愤怒。愤怒是悲伤中一个非常剧烈的阶段，但我认为这是你必须经历的过程。对自己感到愤怒，对对方感到愤怒，对现状感到愤怒。我记得当时发现自己对自己无比愤怒，气自己怎么容许自己陷入一段并不适合我的关系里这么长时间，以至于现在不得不经历这段如此剧烈的心碎期。我当初就应该直接不开始这段感情，这太荒谬了。
But the anger, I think, a big element of it is it's not rational and it's not necessarily something you can control either. Bargaining. You know, typically how people would see. bargaining in relation to a breakup is wanting to get back together with them, trying to, you know, kind of have a discussion with yourself about, oh, you know, eventually we'll get back together. Like, it's in the future, you know, we're meant to be together. We'll get back together or bargaining around like, oh, I'm just going to find someone better. I'm just going to, you know,
但对于愤怒，我认为其中很大一部分原因是它既不理性，也未必是你所能控制的。讨价还价。通常人们如何看待与分手相关的“讨价还价”呢？就是想要复合，试图去，你知道的，在脑海里和自己争论，“哦，（我们）最终还是会复合的。这只是时间问题，你知道的，我们天生就该在一起。我们会复合的”，或者围绕着类似这样的想法进行讨价还价：“哦，我总能找到更好的人。”“哦，我要是，
if I do these things, I'll feel great in a couple of weeks. If I go and sleep with someone else, I'll feel fine. It's basically yourself kind of trying to convince, you're trying to convince yourself that there's an easy way out, which I'm sure you know there isn't. And when it doesn't work, we have depression, perhaps the longest stage of the breakup and the most acute, where you just feel shit. You just feel awful. You feel sad, you feel lonely, you miss that person so much.
如果我做这些事，我在几周内就会感觉好多了。如果我和别人发生关系，我就会感觉没事了。”这基本上是你自己试图说服自己，你试图说服自己有一条捷径可走，而你很清楚根本没有。当这些都不起作用时，我们就迎来了抑郁，这也许是分手最长、也最剧烈的阶段，在这个阶段你只会觉得糟透了。你只会觉得痛苦不堪。你感到悲伤，感到孤独，无比想念那个人。
You know, you're probably looking back through all the photos and fun times you had of them. Sometimes it's actually, at least I think, really good to embody that period and to really let yourself feel that emotion like you would, anything else. You know, if you were physically hurt, I would hope you wouldn't just ignore it. But in another sense, I think it's actually can be quite nice and a little bit indulgent in a good way to just let yourself be sad. Let yourself really be sad about what could have been, about what you miss about that person. Because if you don't, and if you try and suppress it, if you try and use,
你知道的，你可能正在翻看所有照片和你们一起度过的快乐时光。有时，至少我认为，真正去体味那段时期、真正让自己去感受那种情绪，就像对待其他事情一样，其实是一件非常好的事。你知道的，如果你身体受了伤，我希望你不会直接无视它。但在另一种意义上，我觉得适度地让自己难过、甚至有一点点沉溺于这种悲伤中，其实也挺美好的，未尝不是一件好事。让自己彻底为可能发生的遗憾难过，为你想念那个人的那些方面感到难过。因为如果你不这样做，如果你试图压抑它，如果你试图借助，
things like, you know, drink or have sex or throw yourself into something else or, you know, stay on, you know, always be on your screen or whatever it is, excessively socialize, you're never actually going to move through this stage. And it's just going to take longer. Everyone has to get through it. If you're going through a breakup, it's just part of the deal. You're going to be really sad for a while. And it's best to make that last a little bit shorter, I think, by just like pushing yourself really into it,
比如，你知道的，喝酒、发生性行为、把精力投入到其他事情中，或者，你知道的，一直盯着屏幕刷手机，无论是什么，疯狂地进行社交，你其实永远无法真正走出这个阶段。而且只会花更长的时间。每个人都必须经历这一切。如果你正在经历分手，这就是代价的一部分。你会在一段时间内非常难过。而我认为，最好的办法就是通过深深地陷入其中、
hitting that kind of low stage and then, you know, building yourself back up. And that's when you get to the final stage of grief, which is acceptance. Acceptance is the key to moving on. It is the golden antidote to everything that's come before. It's realizing that you're not going to be with that person. That person is no longer yours, in a sense. You are probably never going to see them again, or at least not in a setting where you probably want to see them again.
触及那个低谷期，然后重新振作起来，从而把这个过程缩短一点。这就是当你达到悲伤的最后阶段时——也就是接受。接受是继续前行的关键。它是对前面所有痛苦的黄金解药。它让你意识到你不会再和那个人在一起了。从某种意义上说，那个人不再属于你了。你可能永远不会再见到他们了，或者至少不会再在那种你可能想见到他们的场合相遇。
you're never going to tell them you love them again you never going to you know kiss them again go on holidays with them again have that same level of intimacy and um it's about really accepting that you do want to be with someone that loves you and someone that you can grow with someone that treats you with respect um that was a point i really had to get to where i was i think in previous breakups where I was like, actually no, like I accept that I do deserve things better. I accept that that was a very beautiful relationship and that we did have a great time, but it's over now. And I think that's the thing that I really stags a lot of people, really trips them up,
你再也不会对他们说“我爱你了”，你再也不会，你知道的，去吻他们，和他们一起去度假，再也没有那种程度的亲密感了。嗯，关键在于真正接受你确实想要和一个真正爱你的人在一起，和一个你可以共同成长的人在一起，一个尊重你的人在一起。嗯，这是我必须达到的一个点，我想在之前的分手经历中也是如此，当时我在想：不，实际上，我接受我确实值得拥有更好的东西。我接受那曾是一段非常美好的感情，我们确实度过了一段美好的时光，但它现在已经结束了。而我认为真正让很多人卡住、真正让他们绊倒的，
is you don't truly let them go. You don't recognize that it's truly over. You always have that thought at the back of your mind of like, yeah, maybe one day we'll get back together. I'll get to see them here. to maybe one day we can we can do this again um and you're not going to be able to move forward unless you get over that essentially unless you really come to terms with that and you can kind of tell if you have it i remember i was like yeah i'm totally over it i've accepted this we're not together anymore and then you know what happens you know what happens they get a new partner they get a new
就是你没有真正放手。你没有意识到这一切真的结束了。你的脑海深处总是留存着这样一个想法：“是的，也许有一天我们会复合的。我会在某个地方再次见到他们，也许有一天我们还能重修旧好”，如果你不摆脱这种想法，你就无法真正向前迈进，除非你真正直面现实。基本上，除非你真正接受了这个事实，否则你是无法走出来的。你可以通过某种方式来检验自己是否真的放下了。我记得我曾想过：“是的，我完全放下了，我接受了这个现实，我们不再是一对儿了。”然后，你知道发生了什么吗？你知道会发生什么，他们有了新伴侣，他们开始了一段新恋情。
relationship and that's the real, I guess, moment of truth in determining whether you really have accepted that it's over or whether you've just been telling yourself that it is. Because when that person gets a new partner, that's when that conclusion that realizes, that realization of like, oh, fuck, like I'm not with this person anymore. They're not with me. This is really done. And I think that's when the breakup can truly kind of set in. If you haven't been through that depression you've just kind of skipped over it and gone straight to like, yeah, it's done, we're over. Like, let's move on. As soon as they get, you know, meet someone new, I think that's really when you, you kind of realize, you kind of realize that you probably hadn't really, really reached that stage yet.
这才是检验你是否真正接受了“一切都结束了”、还是仅仅在自欺欺人的真正“真相时刻”。因为当那个人有了新伴侣时，那才是真正的结论，那种意识到“哦，操，我不再和这个人在一起了。他们不再属于我了。这一切真的结束了”的现实感才会击中你。我想这才是分手真正尘埃落定的时刻。如果你没有经历过那个抑郁的阶段，而是直接跳过了它，径直走向类似“是的，结束了，我们分开了，我们向前看吧”的状态，那么一旦他们有了新恋情，一旦他们遇到了新的人，我想那才是你真正意识到，你其实并没有真正达到接受阶段的时刻。
And I think one way to get to that acceptance stage is kind of having a bit of a funeral for your love. And I know this is really, really strange, but it's something that I have done that really, that really, helps me and really has helped me in the past make a box of all the things they gave you all your little mementos um you know cards they wrote you gifts they gave you tickets to things that you did together photos whatever it may be put it in a box and put it away and i think write them almost like a bit of a eulogy a bit of a letter saying you know yeah really acknowledging how much you loved them saying all the things that you really loved about them, that you really saw in them, the best things about them,
我想，达到接受阶段的方法之一，就是为你的爱情举办一场葬礼。我知道这听起来非常非常奇怪，但这确实是我做过的事情，它真的、真的很有帮助，过去也确实帮助我在过去制作了一个装满他们送给你的所有东西的盒子——你所有的那些小纪念品，嗯，你知道的，他们给你写的卡片、他们送给你的礼物、你们一起去过的地方的门票、照片，无论那可能是什么，把它放在一个盒子里，然后把它收起来。而且我认为，最好是给他们写一封类似于悼词、类似于信件的东西，上面写着，你知道的，真正承认你曾多么深爱他们，写下所有你真正爱他们的特质、你在他们身上看到的优点、他们身上最美好的部分，
and then also taking a moment to realize why it probably wasn't meant to be. Sometimes I think when we are in that depression stage of that stage of grief, we look back on our relationships with rose-tinted lenses, and we really tend to forget the awful times. It's a terrible type of cognitive dissonance. You just look back and you think, oh, you know, how amazing was it when we were on this, like, beautiful trip together and like, how amazing was it when we did this and, you know, how amazing was it when we had this experience
然后同时也花一点时间去意识到，为什么这段感情可能注定无法走到最后。有时我认为，当我们处于悲伤的抑郁阶段时，我们会带着玫瑰色的滤镜回顾我们的感情，我们往往会忘记那些糟糕的时刻。这是一种糟糕的认知失调。你只是回过头去想：“哦，你知道的，当我们一起去这趟美丽的旅行时，那是多么不可思议啊；当我们做这件事时，那是多么不可思议啊；当我们有这种经历时，那是多么不可思议啊……”
not remembering all the times in between when perhaps you didn't feel loved and you didn't feel respected or not, you know, remembering the fact that if they wanted to, they would be with you and then not for a reason. Write that letter, it's going to be really hard. You will probably have a few tears and it's actually a really good thing to feel sad when you're doing it because you're sitting back, you're acknowledging both the gratitude you have for them, but also your fears and also in some ways the reasons why it did have to have to end. If the funeral idea is a little bit weird for you, I totally get it. I'm just saying it works. I have like a few boxes of like X's stuff that I like keep in my attic and you know maybe I'll pull it out one day but it's safe there now
却记不起中间所有那些你可能觉得不被爱、不被尊重的时刻，或者不记得这样一个事实：如果他们真的想，他们就会和你在一起，而他们离开是有原因的。写下那封信吧，这会非常艰难。你可能会掉几滴眼泪，而在写的时候感到悲伤其实是一件好事，因为你在回顾，你既承认了你对他们的感激，也承认了你的恐惧，并在某种程度上承认了这段感情为什么必须要结束的原因。如果“葬礼”这个主意对你来说有点奇怪，我完全理解。我只是说它管用。我的阁楼里就藏着好几个装有前任东西的盒子，你知道的，也许有一天我会把它拿出来，但它们现在在那很安全。
but if that's not really your thing keep a diary or some way of tracking your progress so this might sound a little bit dramatic but the first breakup I ever went through I was so distraught I don't even know that was the worst I don't even know how to explain it I was just so sad I was crying all the time I was just like miserable and my psychologist at the time said you should film this you should film yourself in this stage every time you're crying every time you get overwhelmed and you think about them pull out your camera and start recording and I did it and every time I was crying about them I would record exactly how I was feeling what I was thinking about that moment and I still have those videos I actually looked at them a few days ago
但如果你真的觉得这不适合你，那就写日记，或者用其他方式来追踪你的进展。这听起来可能有点戏剧化，但我经历的第一场分手，我是如此心烦意乱，我甚至不知道这算不算是最糟糕的，我甚至不知道该怎么解释，我当时就是太难过了，一直在哭，简直痛苦不堪。我当时的心理医生说：“你应该把这个拍下来，在这个阶段把你自己拍下来，每次你哭泣的时候，每次你情绪崩溃、想到他们的时候，拿出你的相机开始记录。”我照做了，每次为他们哭泣时，我都会准确记录下当时的感受和想法。我到现在还保留着这些视频，其实我几天前刚看过。
in thinking about this episode, fuck it was sad, but you know what else? It was kind of beautiful. It's like 35 minutes of just like clips of me like in tears in different locations around you know, Canberra and Melbourne. And I just looked, watched it back and I was like, that's just crazy that I was feeling that emotion so intensely. And I can look at this now and realize how far I've come. And it's a great way to kind of see that you are moving forward. And yeah, progress isn't linear, but at the end of the day, when you do watch them back in the future, you're just going to kind of laugh at yourself, you know, feel a little bit of pity, but also just have that moment of like, hurrah, I did it, I made it through that. I'm actually not
在回想这一集的时候，操，真的很悲伤，但你知道吗？还有点美妙。这就像是大约35分钟的视频片段，记录了我带着泪水出现在你知道的堪培拉和墨尔本的各个地方。我回看的时候就在想，我当时的情绪居然能如此强烈，这真是太疯狂了。我现在看着这些，能意识到自己已经走出了多远。这也是一种极好的方式，能让你看到自己在向前迈进。是的，进步不是线性的，但归根结底，当你将来再回看这些视频时，你只会有点嘲笑自己，会感到一丝怜悯，但同时也会有一种“太棒了，我做到了，我挺过来了”的时刻。我其实已经不再
that person anymore. Some more strategies, the classic one, and one that I do really stand by, block them, block them, put them in spam, at least for a little while, don't have any contact. I know it's really, really hard. I know you don't want to do it. Trust me, I've been there. If you don't feel like you can do that right now, I think also, you know, if you have things that tie you together, like maybe you lived with them and you've got bank accounts you need to deal with, or you've got leases that you need to deal with, or furniture or shared property or cars or anything like that, obviously it doesn't make sense to block them straight away because A, that's rude, B, that's irresponsible.
是那种人了。再来分享一些策略，最经典的一个，也是我非常支持的一个：拉黑他们，拉黑他们，把他们扔进垃圾箱（垃圾邮件），至少暂时这么做，不要有任何联系。我知道这真的、真的很艰难。我知道你不想这么做。相信我，我经历过。如果你觉得自己现在做不到这一点，我也觉得，你知道，如果你有什么事情把你们牵绊在一起，比如你可能跟他们同居过，有需要处理的银行账户，有需要处理的租约，或者家具、共有财产、汽车之类的，显然，马上拉黑他们是不合情理的，因为A，这很粗鲁；B，这很不负责任。
But put them in spam. Put them in spam and then give yourself like 30 minutes in the day where you can think about them and you can reply to them and you can do whatever you want. And then outside of that 30 minutes, put them away. There's nothing that needs to be done within 24 hours that they can't wait for. And it really stopped you from getting those notifications
但把他们设为垃圾邮件（拒收）。把他们设为垃圾邮件，然后每天给自己留出大概30分钟的时间，你可以去想他们，可以回复他们，想干什么都行。在那30分钟之外，把他们搁在一边。没有什么事情是必须在24小时内解决、他们等不了的。这确实能阻止你收到那些通知
or being reminded of them when you don't want to think about them, having them pop up to you on Instagram when you're spending time with your friends. You know how shitty that is? It's just like the worst feeling because it makes you feel like you've made no progress. It pulls you away from the moment and it keeps you in the loop. So I would say if you can't block them, at least put them in spam. That is my biggest tip. And when you do get the option to block them, do it.
或者在你不想想起他们的时候被他们勾起回忆，当你在跟朋友共度时光时，让他们突然在你的Instagram上弹出来。你知道那有多逊吗？那简直是糟糕透顶的感觉，因为它会让你觉得自己毫无进展。它把你的注意力从当下拉开，让你继续陷入那个循环中。所以我想说，如果你不能拉黑他们，至少把他们设为垃圾邮件。这是我最大的建议。当你终于有机会拉黑他们时，果断拉黑。
It is just amazing and I think really helps contribute to that acceptance of like we're not together anymore. I'm not going to see this person anymore. I shouldn't have any contact. My friend Phoebe, God bless her, if she's listening. absolute legend. She said this to me, in my most recent experience of heartache, she goes, if you don't have contact with them, if they're not in your life, if you're not seeing them, if you're not getting notifications from them, if they're not present in your daily kind of routine, you can kind of forget that they even exist. If they're not in your like periphery,
这真的很神奇，而且我认为这确实有助于建立这样一种接受态度：我们再也不在一起了。我再也不会见到这个人了。我不该有任何联系。我的朋友菲比（Phoebe），上帝保佑她，如果她在听的话，绝对是个传奇。她在最近一次我经历心碎时对我说过这样的话，她说：“如果你跟他们没有联系，如果他们不在你的生活里，如果你见不到他们，如果你收不到他们的通知，如果他们不再出现在你日常的某种常规生活中，你甚至会忘记他们曾经存在过。”如果他们不在你的视线边缘，
if they're not in your like field of vision, either on your phone or, you know, by seeing them, you can move forward a lot faster. And I think that kind of links to this next idea of like keep yourself busy. Although I've said like it's important to really feel your emotions, keeping yourself busy is just like so useful when you are in that like really terrible stage. Reconnect with your friends. Reconnect with the things that you might have given up that we naturally give up when we become intertwined and connected with someone else.
如果他们不在你的视野范围内，无论是在手机上还是通过见到他们，你就能更快地向前迈进。我觉得这跟下一个观点息息相关，那就是：让自己忙起来。尽管我说过真正去感受自己的情绪很重要，但在你处于那种糟糕透顶的阶段时，让自己忙起来真的是太管用了。重新联系你的朋友。重新拾起那些你可能已经放弃的事物——当我们与另一个人深度交织、紧密相连时，我们会自然而然地放弃这些东西。
and I think that is also relevant to creating new parts of you, pursuing new things that, you know, they don't have some connection to new parts of you that are just yours, hobbies and new friends, they're a great place to start, you know, try a new sport, go hiking, go see new places. And I think that's a massive thing. I remember I went, like, when I was in Canberra and I went through this like breakup with one of my exes, everywhere I go would just remind me of them and it was so painful it was so terrible but I started visiting new places that had no connection with them that were just mine and by doing that I got to create and recreate my identity outside of that relationship and outside of my you know of us together
而且我认为这对于塑造全新的自我、追求那些跟他们没有瓜葛的新事物也同样重要——那些只属于你自己的新部分。兴趣爱好和新朋友，它们是一个很好的起点，比如尝试一项新运动、去远足、去看看新的地方。我认为这是一个巨大的改变。我记得当我住在堪培拉、经历与其中一个前任的分手时，我去的每一个地方都会让我想起他们，那是如此痛苦，如此糟糕。但我开始去一些全新的地方，那里跟他们没有任何联系，只属于我自己。通过这样做，我得以在那种关系之外、在我们共同生活之外，去建立和重塑我的身份。
and it was a really great way to kind of move forward and to reconnect with myself and see myself as not just theirs not just their girlfriend not just their person but as Gemma, as my own person who has their own things that they don't have any touch or hold or fingers in that they don't have any connection to. And I think that's a really important step and hopefully a good strategy for you if you're, you are in that situation where you're just in a loop of being reminded of them of feeling like everything you do is in some way theirs as well. Okay, so what next? What next? You've done the work. You've invested in yourself, you've invested in your hobbies.
这真的是一种极好的方式，能让我向前迈进，重新与自己建立联系，并把自己看作不仅仅是“他们的附属品”、不仅仅是他们的女朋友、不仅仅是属于谁的人，而是作为一个杰玛（Gemma），作为一个独立的人，拥有属于自己的、他们完全触及不到、没有掌控权、没有沾染也毫无关联的事物。我认为这是一个非常重要的步骤，如果你恰好处于那种不断被提醒想起他们、觉得你做的一切在某种程度上也属于他们的循环中，希望这能成为对你很有帮助的一个策略。好了，那么接下来呢？接下来怎么办？你已经完成了这些工作。你投资了自己，投资了你的兴趣爱好。
You've invested in your friends. You've cut off contact. You have gone to therapy, a big one. My friend Aaron would always say that. Go to therapy. You have moved through. You've gone through that grieving process. Where do you go from there?
你投资了你的朋友。你切断了联系。你去看心理医生了，这很重要。我的朋友阿伦（Aaron）总是这么说：去看心理医生。你已经走过来了。你已经经历了那个悲伤的过程。从那以后你该去哪里？
What do you do? Not just in relation to them, but in relationship to your broader relationships as well. The first thing I think we all think about is like, is it possible to be friends with your ex. I actually think it is. This is not based on any kind of research, just like personal experience. I think that you had a really deep connection with them
你该做些什么？不仅仅是针对他们，也是为了处理你更广泛的人际关系。我们首先想到的第一件事大概是：和前任做朋友可能吗？其实我觉得是可以的。这并不是基于什么研究，纯粹是个人经验。我觉得你和他们之间曾有过非常深的羁绊，
for a reason. Perhaps you would have been better as friends, you know, this whole time. But if you have successfully moved through those stages, if you no longer see them as a romantic interest, if you no longer, and this is critical, no longer have any expectations for a future romantic or intimate relationship with them, I think it is possible. I think it's possible to reintroduce them to your life
这是有原因的。也许你们从一开始就更适合做朋友。但是，如果你已经成功地走过了那些阶段，如果你不再把他们当作浪漫的对象，如果你不再——这一点至关重要——对未来与他们发展浪漫或亲密关系抱有任何期望，我认为这是可能的。我认为重新把他们引回你的生活是可行的，
slowly and making sure it's not derailing any progress you've made or that, you know, you're putting too much attention on them or you really are secretly thinking like, oh yeah, this is it, we're going to get back together this time. But if you're no longer in that thought process, I do think it's possible. I had this with one of my exes. who I love very deeply and who is now, I would say, a very good friend of mine. And after a while, we had a large period of separation. We both went on and dated different people. And then slowly we just started to become friends,
只要慢慢来，确保这没有破坏你已经取得的进展，或者确保你没有把过多的注意力放在他们身上，也没有在心底偷偷想着：“哦，太好了，这次我们又要复合了。”但如果你已经不再处于那种思维过程中，我确实认为这是可能的。我和我的一个前任就是这样，我深爱着他，现在可以说他是我非常好的朋友。过了一段时间后，我们经历了一段很长的分离期。我们都继续前行，和不同的人约会了。然后慢慢地，我们开始重新成为朋友，
the way that you would become friends with a stranger, just like thinking about things you had in common, you know, having a laugh with them every now and again, helping them out with like some random thing and keeping it at that level, or not letting it get any deeper. I remember the moment I realized that, like, I truly was, like, just, like, actually just good pals with this person
就像你和陌生人成为朋友那样，只是聊聊你们的共同点，偶尔一起开开玩笑，帮对方处理一些杂七杂八的事情，并把关系维持在这个水平，不让它变得更深。我记得我真正意识到自己和这个人“真的、只是、纯粹变成好哥们儿”的那个瞬间，
was when I was talking to them about another relationship I was in, and he was doing the same. And there was no feeling of jealousy. There was no feeling of, like, sadness. It was just as if I was talking to any of my other friends about something I was going through. Yeah, that's actually, I would say, you know, a rare thing to achieve, and it's definitely not for everyone.
是我在跟他聊我正在经历的另一段感情，而他也同样在聊他的感情。当时没有任何嫉妒的感觉，也没有任何难过的感觉。那种感觉就好像我在跟自己的任何其他朋友倾诉我正在经历的事情一样。是的，实际上，我想说，这是一种很难达到的状态，而且绝对不适合所有人。
and I would say if you can't keep up healthy boundaries with that person, if that person has really hurt you or done something that's like genuinely abhorrent or like terrible, in no way should you feel like you have to be friends with them again or should you feel obligated. Cut them off, get them out of your fucking life. But if you have that inclination and if it's natural and if it works, I do think that there is something to be said about being friends with your ex and keeping them in your life at a healthy distance.
我想说的是，如果你无法与那个人保持健康的界限，如果那个人真的深深伤害了你，或者做了什么真正令人发指或糟糕透顶的事，你绝不应该觉得自己必须和他们做回朋友，或者觉得自己有这种义务。切断联系，让他们滚出你的狗屁生活。但如果你有这种倾向，如果这一切都很自然且行之有效，我确实认为，与前任做朋友并将他们以健康的距离保留在你的生活中，是有其道理的。
I think the other thing is, when do you know that you're ready to date again? I don't think you ever know. I think there will just come a point where you'll just realize that that's actually an option now and that you are in the right place to be able to meet someone new, to give it another shot and to share things with yourself. A big hurdle, I think there's two things I really want to say about that. if you're just dating because you're trying to get over that person, I don't think that's that great. Firstly, you're just going to end up hurting yourself more.
我觉得另一件事是，你如何知道自己已经准备好再次开始约会了？我觉得你永远不会“知道”。我想总会有一个时刻，你突然意识到这其实已经成了一种选项，你正处于合适的状态去遇见新的人，去再次尝试并与人分享你的生活。一个巨大的障碍——关于这一点我有两点特别想说：如果你约会只是为了试图忘掉那个人，我觉得这并不怎么好。首先，你最终只会让自己受到更深的伤害。
It's also not fair to those other people either. And I don't actually think it's a healthy way to move through grief. You're just using dating and other people as a distraction. And you're always, I think, looking to those people that you're seeing to be like that person you were just with. with it's just like such an unhealthy expectation to place on every single possible party in that situation. I also think the other thing that comes into it is your self-confidence levels. And feeling as if you are yourself again, if you do have something to share, if your life would at this stage be better with someone else. My friend Kate is incredible, just an incredible,
这对其他人来说也不公平。而且我其实不认为这是度过悲伤的健康方式。你只是把约会和他人当成一种分心的工具。而且我觉得，你总是会在你所约会的人身上寻找刚刚离开的那个人的影子——把这种不健康的期待强加给这种情况下的每一个可能的相关方，简直太不健康了。我还认为，牵涉其中的另一件事是你的自信心水平。你要觉得自己重新找回了自我，如果你确实有什么可以分享的，如果在这个阶段有另一个人加入会让你的生活变得更好。我的朋友凯特（Kate）太棒了，简直是一个极其不可思议的人。
incredible person. And I just remember her saying, like, she just made, like, she, after she went through like a hard period, a hard, like breakup heart, heartbreak thing, she just focused really intently on making her life as amazing as possible, as suited to what she wanted as possible. So when someone did come along, the only thing left for them to do was just to already elevate what she already knew she had, which was happiness, which was friends, which was opportunities, and which was gratitude. I think that's a really successful and amazing way to go about it. And making sure that you're at a point where you feel like you could be vulnerable with someone again. That was a big thing and still a big thing for me, I think, where, although like I'm definitely not actively dating or anything like that,
我记得她说过，在经历了一段艰难的时期、一段艰难的分手和心碎之后，她非常专注于一件事：让自己的生活尽可能地精彩，尽可能符合她自己的期望。所以当某个人真正出现时，他们唯一需要做的，就是去提升她原本就已经拥有的那些东西——也就是快乐、朋友、机遇和感恩。我认为这是一种非常成功且了不起的生活方式。并且要确保你处于这样一个阶段：你觉得你能够再次向某人敞开心扉、展露脆弱。这曾经是一个巨大的转折点，对现在的我来说依然如此，虽然我绝对没有在积极约会或做什么，
a big reason behind me not doing that is because I just, A, don't feel the need to, but B, just think there's so much work left to be done. myself around my confidence levels after like my recent experience and just feeling like I am myself again and that if someone met me tomorrow if like my soulmate met me tomorrow they would actually like the person I am and the person I am is actually a reflection of who I want to be and a reflection of my values and my principles and not of you know my self-esteem issues you know it's a lot if you work through your baggage early it's a less weight and less burden on your future relationships, I think. You're doing yourself a favor for the future. You're doing them a favor. There's not really much else to be said about it other than that. And before we wrap up
我不这么做的很大一部分原因在于：A，我没有这个需求；B，我觉得自己在经历最近的事件后，在重建自信方面还有很多工作要做，我需要重新找回真实的自我，确保如果明天有人遇到我——如果我的灵魂伴侣明天遇到我——他们会真心喜欢现在的我，而现在的我想成为的人正是我价值观和原则的体现，而不是我那些自卑情结的产物。你知道的，如果你早点处理好自己的心理包袱，未来的感情关系就会少很多重量和负担。你在为自己的未来做打算，也是在为对方做打算。除了这些，其实也没什么好说的了。在我们结束
this episode, if you are going through a breakup, I send you a lot of love. I know how it feels. I know it can feel really terrible, but do focus on the really good parts of the relationship for a while. Let yourself feel pain. Let yourself feel the love that you do. You feel the love that have for them at least for a period and, you know, be grateful for that relationship and then really get to work on accepting that it's not part of your life anymore. It's not part of your future. It's not part of your reality. And it's time to move on. It's time to be with someone who's more compatible. Be with someone who can give you what you want and who can give you what you really deserve because you deserve, I think, so much more. If that relationship didn't work, it didn't
这一集之前，如果你正在经历分手，我向你送去满满的爱。我知道那是什么感觉。我知道这感觉可能会糟糕透顶，但在一段时间里，请务必专注于这段关系中真正美好的部分。允许自己去感受痛苦。允许自己去感受你对他们的爱，至少在一段时间里感受你对他们的爱，并且对这段关系心怀感激，然后真正开始努力去接受这样一个事实：他们不再是你生活的一部分了。他们不再是你未来的一部分。他们不再是你的现实。是时候前行了。是时候和更合拍的人在一起了。和那些能给你想要的东西、能真正给你应得之物的人在一起，因为我觉得你值得拥有更多更好的。如果那段关系行不通，它行不通
work for a reason. Remind yourself of that. It didn't work for a reason. It might not be their fault. It might not be, it's definitely not your fault. It might not be anyone's fault. Sometimes people just don't work because there's friction, because there's incompatibilities. And that's all right. And you don't have to get back together with them. You shouldn't feel like you need to. There's someone a lot better out there. And even if you're by yourself for five, ten years, that's just such a great opportunity to make yourself into the best version of you, not for your future partner, not for your future, you know, boyfriend or girlfriend or partner or whatever, but just for you and just because, you know, on this stuff, you really do only have yourself. And that's just the
是有原因的。提醒自己这一点。它行不通是有原因的。这不一定是他们的错，当然也绝对不是你的错。可能谁都没有错。有时人们合不来，只是因为有摩擦，因为存在不兼容。这没关系。你不需要和他们复合。你不需要觉得有这个必要。外面还有更好得多的人。哪怕你独自生活五年、十年，这也是一个绝佳的机会，能让自己变成最好的版本——不是为了未来的伴侣，不是为了你未来的男朋友或女朋友或伴侣之类的，而只是为了你自己，只是因为在这个世界上，你真的只能靠自己。而这才是
most crucial element, I think. If nothing else, if you take nothing else, you really do only have yourself. So the investment you put into your identity, your character, how you feel about yourself, how you feel in relation to others, whether you're proud of yourself, whether you love yourself is so much more important than whether you love someone else and whether they love you. So yes, I hope you enjoyed this episode. I thought it was going to be a lot more emotional than it was. I guess it's a testament to having moved through this successfully. Congratulations, Gemma. But I hope it also gave you some insight. It gave you something to think about and some strategies, some advice. Time is just your best friend in this situation. It's a brilliant
最关键的要素，我认为。如果其他什么都没听进去，至少要记住这一点：你真的只能靠自己。因此，你对自己的身份、性格、自我感觉、与他人相处时的感受所投入的投资，你是否为自己感到骄傲，你是否爱自己，这些都远比你是否爱另一个人、他们是否爱你要重要得多。所以，是的，希望你喜欢这一集。我本以为它会比实际表现得更有情绪感一些。我想这也是成功走过来的证明吧。恭喜你，杰玛。但我也希望它能给你带来一些洞察。它能给你提供一些思考、一些策略和一些建议。时间就是你在这种情况下的最好朋友。关于时间，有一件
and worst thing about time. It always moves forward and you will as well. And it really does heal all wounds, at least partially, along with some good hard work and some therapy. You'll get to a point where you can look back on yourself in this stage, like I looked back at those videos of me crying when I was like 19 and just feel just a little bit silly about it but also just so much it's just such a strange feeling it's just such a strange feeling to be looking back at yourself in the past and just acknowledging how far you've come and just thinking back on those feelings and how you never thought it was going to end and then eventually it does and if you did like this episode please feel free to subscribe or leave us a review on Apple Podcasts or Spotify podcasts
既棒又糟的事情，那就是它总是向前流逝，你也会如此。伴随着一些刻苦的努力和心理治疗，它确实能治愈所有的伤痛，至少能治愈一部分。你会到达这样一个阶段：你可以回看自己在这一阶段的模样，就像我回看那些19岁时自己哭泣的视频一样，只会觉得有点傻气，但同时也有着极其复杂的情感——回看过去的自己，意识到自己已经走了多远，回想起那些曾经以为永远不会结束的情感，而最终它还是结束了。如果你喜欢这一集，请随时订阅，或者在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或Spotify播客上给我们留下评价。
it really does help this show grow. If this is an episode you think someone else in your life would really appreciate it, would really appreciate or really needs, send it to them. I would be really grateful if you would do that. And follow us on Instagram as well at 20's Psychology Podcast. I know it's a weird handle. I'm trying to change it. I don't really know how to.
这真的对这个节目的成长有很大帮助。如果你觉得这一集是你生活中的某个人会真正感激、非常欣赏或真正需要的，请把它发给他们。如果你能这样做，我将不胜感激。也请在Instagram上关注我们，账号是 20's Psychology Podcast。我知道这个名字有点奇怪。我正试图改掉它。我其实还不知道怎么改。
But sometimes we do questions there for topic ideas or things you want to hear about. So please feel free to send your suggestions over there. I'm sending you a lot of peace, love and happiness. If you are moving through your breakup and some heartbreak at the moment, it's going to get better. And you're on the right path. If you're listening to podcasts, I think you're getting into that acceptance stage. So best of luck, and thank you for listening.
但有时我们会在那里征集问题作为节目主题的灵感，或者收集你想听的内容。所以请随时把你的建议发到那边。我向你发送满满的平和、爱与快乐。如果你此刻正经历分手和心碎，一切都会好起来的。你正走在正确的道路上。如果你在听播客，我想你已经进入了接受的阶段。所以祝你好运，感谢收听。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
嘿，最近过得怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都实在不够安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得如何操作的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人随身带着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的教训》。2%。这就是当旁边还有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在 我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
这就是《2%》，可在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过时，她们决定自己动手解决问题。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说：相信你的好姐妹。听听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。可在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一档iHeart播客。100%真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。